I am good morning how are you good
morning Dan
how many Russians I don't understand I
don't know either I have no idea McLovin
has a half hour to figure that out all
right how do you how do you prepare now
I know the Dolphins run this play they
practice this play I don't know if you
were there on Saturdays practice or
walkthrough but did you have any idea
what kind of play they had in store here
no no the the two things I would say one
Gronkowski comes on the field which
indicates New England thinks it's going
to be a Hail Mary but the point I made
at that juncture was they had seven
seconds left I thought Miami would throw
a quick hitter try to pick up seven
eight yards on the outside get out of
bounds and then try for a Hail Mary from
60 62 yards away
if Tannehill could heat it we've seen
this countless times this is actually
fairly rudimentary in the NFL at the end
of games you have these chaotic moments
laterals flags bedlam and it never works
out I've called them who knows how many
times in the NFL as a play-by-play guy a
Hail Mary you can build up to there is a
moment where you know there will be
finality this play I think took
everybody's not by surprise including
the New England Patriots because they
executed it so well and it was actually
very fairly crisp for a lateral play to
happen that way so a play-by-play
announcer what do you do you shift gears
make sure you're accurate make sure that
you are coherent you're speaking English
and make sure you convey the emotion of
the moment that's the mental checklist
that you go through and in the five
seconds that you have as the thing
develops
the one thing I wondered is could
Tannehill have even thrown it 75 yards
therefore why do you have Gronk back
there to knock something down
I just didn't understand the strategy
with the Patriots and look it could have
ended that Miami lost the game and you
know fumble the ball or whatever I just
I I thought they were set up for
something that Miami was not capable of
doing yeah and that's a fair statement
that probably plays more into at least
my thought of all right they're gonna
throw a quick hitter Gronk is already on
the field then they'll try the Hail Mary
that might have been Bill Belichick
thought process at that point the
reality is look nobody is above reproach
in this league and when it comes to
sports and even with all the equity that
bill has built up and nobody has built
up more equity there's no one that has
more capital than Bill Belichick when it
comes to making decisions football
related but looking at it it seems
pretty obvious that Gronk did not belong
on the field in that situation and there
is a chance they had a safety there a
normal safety could make a tackle on
Kenyan Drake where Rob Gronkowski is not
normally put in that position
the stumble just added to it and yeah
bill may have outsmarted himself that
that's that's a very fair statement to
make
do you play things out in your mind as
to what if any how you react in that
situation not as much it's just a pretty
normal setup for end of games where they
end with a with a plunk there's nothing
to it truly having done this now for 21
years with CBS I've never been in that
situation where it's worked where the
last final gasp works
I've called Hail Marys I had Aaron
Rodgers on the radio a couple years ago
with Detroit and again there's a natural
build in how you approach a call like
that with this it's it's basically the
the end of a game if
anything Dan in that situation I'm
thinking about game ends what are the
headlines New England has won its 10th
straight division that's an NFL record
they will make the playoffs clinching a
berth for the 10th straight year
that's an NFL record those are the the
thoughts that are swimming around my
head Patriots have had trouble in Miami
it's been a house of horrors for that so
they overcame that obviously you make a
quick shift when something like that
happens and and you just hope your
instincts kick in
also when you have a moment like that it
just feels like the right thing to do is
not say anything so once we know it's a
touchdown you've established it's a
touchdown then you just lay out take the
different camera angles there but how do
you let your your color analyst Dan
Fouts know I'm not saying anything we
shouldn't say anything there was that
just again what Dad and yeah Dan he he's
been doing this forever and I don't know
if I've worked with anyone that has more
of an understanding of the play-by-play
color commentator dynamic than Dan Fouts
because he's Cole play-by-play his dad
was a play-by-play guy and longtime
play-by-play man in the San Francisco
area and he just gets it
so that's never an issue he's never one
to jump on top of something he
understands laying out letting it
breathe and even at the end of the call
that you just played I jumped back in I
did believe there was a moment there
where we've seen a multitude of shots
and now you need a little more context
stating that the laterals are legal that
this is going to stand that this was
miraculous just those moments of ok tie
it all together because I'm sure people
watching at home this is what's dancing
around my head they just want to know
did this count yeah is this real is this
really happening and the shock on the
faces of the players on the field that
that told a story in it of itself but
you're talking about in the moment you
should have said and hey that's a legal
lateral or are you talking about once
we've already had the celebration and
then you back
yes and then clean it up yeah the call
you just played if if it picked up you
would hear all those things that I just
detailed that's that's what was on the
air following the the reaction and those
great pictures Bob Fisher and our
director Mark wolf our producer they
were all over it and as you stated
before it's not something you can
prepare for just like New England wasn't
ready for as a TV crew you're taught to
cover the moment but you're also
planning for the game to end that's part
of you're off the air sequence and
obviously they had to make a very quick
change and did it with with incredible
ease Chuck an eye on eagle CBS Sports
NFL play by play voice had the Patriots
dolphins he'll be doing the Dolphins
Vikings coming up next weekend is that
the wild is finished you've ever been
involved in oh yeah I would have to say
just the nature of it I've been really
fortunate to call some incredible
finishes yeah I did the Duke Butler game
in 2010 on the world feed I'm huge in
Indonesia the 98 NBA Finals I did Game
six the Jordan Brian Russell game world
feed Ray Allen jumper against San
Antonio 2013 last year Cincinnati
Baltimore if you remember that game in
week 17 the touchdown Andy Dalton threw
that propelled Buffalo into the playoff
that again was unlikely and a fantastic
finish those are some of the games that
popped him I had NCAA Tournament games
Wake Forest West Virginia o-5 Chris
Paul's last game at Wake Forest NBA
games locally nets and Suns with your
buddy Mark Jackson was a double overtime
161 157 final net spacers and o2 when
Jason Kidd put the team on his back and
got the team to the second round in a
game five at the time it was best three
out of five against Indiana just a bunch
of games that that popped into my head
but that one
that one's gonna stand out for a while
is there a name that you hate as a
broadcaster no I've been I've been
fairly ok with pronunciations when your
name is ayan you better not screw up
people's names like your your
credibility is is going to come under
question if you're not getting their
name right have you ever thought of
maybe changing it to Ian it's not my
decision my parents made this decision
now you can you it's yours it's yours it
doesn't sound as good
Ian Eagle it's at the e in the e it
doesn't jive I and Eagle sounds much
better trust me it would have been
easier I went up to Dallas two weeks ago
this is the first time I've gotten this
one I went to check into the hotel and I
said hey check an end last name eagle
and they start tapping the keyboard and
they said Ivan yeah okay yeah just you
know a little bit too much emphasis on I
and I know you're a team player so I
think that or maybe you're not a team
player
I in no no I'm a solo artist I remember
vividly Chris who a Matamata fallen I
don't love that dam and thinking to
myself yeah I think it myself
all right I've got I got no shot I'm
gonna screw this up at some point but I
I said it so often over and over that
that became one of the easiest names for
me to say other play-by-play guys would
say foo and they'd sure nan like no you
have to go for it you have to you have
to commit so the fool Amata masala
became very much part of my go-to even
if he wasn't in the game I'd mention
he's on the sideline just to show what
about the Greek freak oh yeah Yanis I
think the kupo same deal yeah it took me
a little while
right iron no no no no no that was its
Yanis auténtico auténtico auténtico okay
what about - etana by law I'm a now anui
no no yeah Michael hole uh manoa nuit
you just you have to go don't don't hold
yourself back it's got to be unbridled
commitment that that's the way that that
I look at this thing
iein congratulations on a great call Dan
good luck again with the dolphins and
the Vikings please tell Dan Fouts we
settle oh I will I will talk to you and
say hello to everybody that's not Ian
I'm gonna give him to you I'm gonna go I
got him I got him eat he's not
Ian's Idol he's Iron Eagle I've gotten
that - thank you I all right that's
irony for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]